[Music]
today we're challenging top basketball
team vus to a game of pingpong
basketball Horse let's go half court
shot you go first let's
[Music]
go don't tell me that's the first try
what was that told you sir there is some
pressure and we have a smaller basket
metal
bin that's it that's
it did it there you go next up no look
3.0 let's do
it didn't all look sure let's make
[Music]
it 1 2 three we're going to have to do a
triple
too one letter to us trust shot he's
saying we shouldn't do it let's see if
I'm any trustworthy have promised you
anything
though that is terrifying I just felt
like this massive thing above me your
turn you just have to be the net that's
I se y'all play ping pong I got trust
okay good you lift the ball and I'll try
and hit it
off safer and
[Music]
safer that was good that was crazy boun
contest against the side of the
backboard I I trust you that you can
keep on going forever if you
want there you got
to got it 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 yeah that's
it two the first letter to
basketball a serve receive are you going
to get it back have the wings span to
get
it he's trying at least all right you
try
oh oh he touched it this
time not bad a lot of
spin oh you got it one out of six next
I'll be defending you have the ladder
there yes I might have to use the ladder
let's go let's get it I'm just going to
try and stop you from scoring okay
no
yeah
no say one
[Music]
more I was trying to go donkey but that
was a good def so I couldn't oh let's
take you to the low post you got to stop
me
almost oh he's so big I'm
terrified hey six out of six okay now
you have to defend me all
right lay off
no me my teammate's going to pass it to
my teammate and my teammate's going to
pass it to me I'm going to be the
[Music]
finisher we're going to try and do exact
same as them but on the
table between the legs between the
legs let's do Ry Punk shots are cool are
cool I like that one
[Music]
yes sir
man that was one of the easiest we've
done so far next up different dribbles
you give me the trick basic front front
triple yeah oh that's easy what about
between the legs you got it you got
it behind the back that's going to be
harder the Bott on your finger okay okay
actually you did
it up to the spider dribble oh yeah two
TAPS in the front and two TAPS in the
back I have no idea what to
[Music]
do behind the back pass with a bounce to
the backboard and a
dunk it's come on time for the pink Rion
let's
[Applause]
go oh no that's still counts EML broke
the does it count though we're getting
destroyed here let's reverse the
professions one point
[Music]
match got this I I do I do I have
this yeah yeah
yeah there we go back spin serve over
the basket and onto my side one of you
can try and receive the
serve I want ready I want ready I just
got here it was two bouns I'll try and
get it with one
[Music]
bounce throw it behind the basket put
back spin on it so that it
bounces into the
basket but it doesn't
[Music]
count still not the trick shot we were
going for two vs2 we have the Rockets
they don't the one basket oh yeah good
handle good handle yeah oh DK
oh oh yeah back down oh back
down we're still in the game M I know we
have a
[Music]
chance that was exhausting time for a
full court shot I have a bad feeling I'm
going to lose this one but let's give it
a shot
close no
luck
oh hey let's
go hey first try there huge thanks to
vas we got beat pretty bad today but we
had a lot of fun pongfinity on three 1 2
pity